is that shot even in the movie where
where Alfred says like I hope you're not
too late no it's not yeah they'd see you
said you've come now that's hope you're
not too late Superman have been just
stop there's some courtesies you can
skip given your powers you don't have to
check with Alfred before finding Bruce
hello hi reject nation Greg Alba here
and it's John over here so I'm assuming
that if you're here you have already
seen Justice League we already have a
non-spoiler review up there's a link in
the description box for that if you
haven't got a chance to catch that
basically a nutshell I just acknowledged
that I thought this one was cheesy corny
flawed but it consistently entertained
me I was always amused no matter what
was going on I think amused and
entertained was the best way I could
describe it yeah I thought it was fine
and I was mildly amused from time to
time I don't know where to begin so I
might just hop into the first day posted
my first flash flash flash doesn't first
name pops in my life right he's in this
he was quick to get these quick buddy
boy flash Ezra Miller
did it such a great job with this role
his comedy in this film you don't care
about me care about him because because
he's like I'm dope and him and Billy
Crudup I like the relationship I'm
pretty much almost caught up to date on
every episode of the flash right now so
I've seen the whole storyline play out
with Barry Allen and his dad being in
jail for a crime he didn't commit and it
was nice seeing that touch and seeing
where Barry Allen's starting point is
here and he is different from grant
gustin's portrayal of the flash they
start him off as more of a bilious yunda
and squatting in a warehouse that
inexplicably has power for many agents
and I thought Azra Miller was so
hilarity had the funniest lines you know
I knew I was loving him here's what he
greets Wonder Woman hears
hi hi Barry I'm not
yeah some of the best and that thread
with his dad the emotional plot lines
are very thin in this but it's he is a
character that gets one and I didn't
like it you know and he has an arc
that's one of the few characters that
has like an actual arc in this film
coming out of his shell man's coming out
of his shell he makes some friends he
bonds and he gets a job by the end of
this movie work at the central city
police station cyborgs though ray Fisher
or Victor the character I was genuinely
surprised it's not funny in this film
you know and I feel like sometimes like
the ones we love the most are the funny
ones but he was this character whose I
found intriguing his powers kept growing
his powers kept it's like once you see
Barry's power okay you get it he's fast
yeah Aquaman can only do so many things
a cyborg was a character really evolving
powers and about him and flash were the
highlights of this film cyborg had the
only story were I was actually
emotionally invested yeah right in his
journey and he really felt like a
character and part of that too is
because this is his introduction and
that's one of the strange ways were
having to introduce characters kinda
does work yes movie a little bit again
you don't get to know him deeply but he
does have like a really kind of
authentic performance yeah you can feel
the conflict you can feel that I'm a
monster sort of thing I'm you know
percolating underneath him and oddly
they introduced him as a dark character
yeah yeah he's a dark character with
these with these powers that he's still
learning to understand and he doesn't
view his stuff as powers skills like he
doesn't want to get involved because he
doesn't want to embrace this as he views
it as bad so through the course of the
film he learned he's learning to embrace
it use it and work with it and he
becomes a part of the team I liked his
approach I liked how he was one of the
more serious characters I thought his
character was actually a very effective
heard some complaints about him and
that's when I'm gonna really disagree
with that I thought he was very
effective it was Aquaman was the one
where I'm like okay he's the one
character in somewhere I thought he
needed a soul of it especially with what
they're doing with his character cuz
they do [ __ ] with his character like
going to Atlantis meeting with giant if
I've ever heard me do it Amber Heard I'm
watching it going see this is one of
those moments that would be cool if he
had a solo yeah
like okay you know pepper pot showed up
it's essential to the plot based off
what the mother boxes are that he would
have to go to Atlantis at the same time
though I know the effect they're trying
to go for but it's just not gonna be
felt because I don't know who the [ __ ]
this person is I don't know yeah yeah
I'm gonna see an isolated portion of
something yeah I don't really know much
about and then I'm gonna have to kind of
forget about that and a few may have you
know and it it does make you want to see
Aquaman because that but it also makes
his character feel just kind of like
he's there you could tell the filmmakers
are very much listening to what people
are complaining about so there's some
stuff that leans way too much of the
opposite side of the spectrum I guess
what everyone just wants is a balance
you see his fish lighting right now
we're waiting for them to finally find
ya you know cuz Wonder Woman had a
balance drama emotion humor had
everything that we wanted was was that
balance yeah and this got a little too
light for an end of the world scenario
it probably would have been easier to
just be cool with that if these guys had
solo movie it's kind of like the first
Avengers you can't help but compare this
to the Avengers when when Steppenwolf
shows up guys I don't really know Stefan
was comic book history but when he shows
up I'm like oh it's Loki Loki shows up
to looking for a box will eventually
become the Allspark the thing is the
Avengers is a pretty light-hearted film
and you'll really need to feel that like
crazy stakes it's effective because
these guys have had solo films before
this you needed that you need even a
better Batman solo film not just the BBS
introduction this is really Aquaman I
feel like there are things about this
that work because of how they've taken
BBS and at least run with what it
implies and so there are things that
that work that that come out of that
yeah but I feel like for Batman's
leadership ability it would have been
great to have a solo yeah first thing a
movie doesn't toy with though which
bothered me
yeah is that its setting that up he
doesn't really know no work with well
with people he's not really comfortable
with leading and he's late in an arc
like yeah I knew he's another version of
Bruce
I need to see and like make some bad
leadership decisions or if he makes a
leadership choice and they don't really
flow they don't really like what the
leaders doing he kind of served more of
a Nick Fury in the field yeah you know
Nick Lahiri came along and punched a few
people yeah like he doesn't really need
to be there but if yous there like
shooting a gun like okay cool yeah but
you really just need to bring the mega
heroes to save the day
yeah and one point even cyborg jumps in
his ship and he's like no no no I got
the way they bring Superman back in this
film using the mother box the old
technology or that brought cyber to life
you're applying the same method it
looked kind of what they did was odd
gonna take him into the the ship yeah
they're gonna go into water do the
meditation tank yeah they're gonna trip
out a little bit learning some things
about themselves Superman's gonna come
back and Superman comes back that was a
genuine nice surprise to me that was one
of my favorite things about this movie
when Superman comes back there's a whole
I thought Superman's gonna be like oh
it's 15 minutes before the movie ends
yeah he's super essential but when
they're all fighting Superman it gives
you like a fun it's not like actually
menacing or dark you don't actually
think Superman's gonna do something
terrible but with the way these films
have gone he comes back clearly not
happy out and you're like I don't know
which direction this is gonna go
actually there are a couple moments like
that that do kind of get meta which
which makes all the superhero poses and
landings so weird because that's a
moment you're like ah I've thought of
that before you could definitely tell
them there's like joss whedon jokes in
this movie yeah like there's this great
bit it was my favorite scene of Aquaman
yeah Aquaman is oh when he gets to have
a character bonus opinion of the whole
team like you and his himself trust you
you finally sing on the lasso of truth
yeah and that's like such a wonderful
moment cause it endears you to Aquaman
and it brings the team kind of closer
together and it's a sort of meta
superhero movie moment it is a moment
where this movie does actually shine
because it does have moments where it
does shine they're just few and far
between
I guess I just felt a little bit like
Aquaman wasn't exactly necessary if you
think about like really think about it
for a second guys he shows up to do an
Aquaman thing one time and that's
because they happen to be under a Gotham
Harbor at the time yeah and he shows it
was just the right time at which which
is cool it feels like he's there to help
the plot with stuff it's like oh one of
the boxes in Atlantis that's an excuse
to have Aquaman here and he's gonna stop
them from being drowned to death in
terms of his powers though he's kind of
just serves a purpose to just help with
punching he's brick in the finale of the
movie you're like he can't do any
Aquaman things yeah yeah he just stabs
and punches I'm like that's essentially
what Wonder Woman's here for but she has
a lot so she's kind of cooler and she
condition yes super high and she also
has a personal like vendetta with
Steppenwolf because she always does
these guns yeah yeah but going back to
Superman Lois Lane we spend so much time
in Atlanta man of steel and you get good
amount of time with her and bbs and
surprisingly I felt like if there's one
thing they actually really fixed was
Superman and Lois Lane yeah because I
liked Lois Lane in this movie there's
this great thing but they're setting up
where Batman says okay if we wake
Superman open you get the big guns you
are thinking says Batman's already been
using guns to fight these parademons as
could be some crazy bat web and there's
self-aware movie moments and then when
Alfred shows up when Superman's gone
crazy and he has Lois you're like that's
always like I actually buy this whole
Superman Lois thing now I liked her okay
and Man of Steel and I did not like her
in BBS and this is the most I've liked
that character at all in that moment she
has with maque Kent - yeah no scene when
they're talking at the Daily Planet was
a great scene that was the first
character scene that I was I thought I
actually was really enjoying yeah and
this is he's Superman - like getting
along with some of the team inside like
the Postgres smiling and having a good
time that was one thing in terms of plot
and course correction that I thought was
well justified because they actually
killed him he was dead the way bbs ends
it's kind of confused to [ __ ] at me
because they showed the Lu
eleventeen dirt you're thinking oh he's
really not dead I'm still alive but then
this movie is like no he's actually
really dead they have to do this whole
crazy processing it's Superman back and
Superman has one line in here that made
me go you know what that does justifies
the whole change of Superman's
personality which is I actually like
being alive yeah and he's back he's
happy to be alive so it makes sense that
he's more smiles
it was brighten up and there's even this
great mid-credits scene that hints had a
great part of comic-book history of
flash and Superman about to react like
that's cool that's really cool
everything was Superman I really liked
and that's really fun come right down to
like that that scene was one of the most
wonderful parts of this movie I think
that was the one part of the whole
experience where I was like oh yeah yeah
you know cuz yeah it's a sea Superman
like that in this iteration almost in a
weird way makes the arc of getting here
a bit better because you see like okay
maybe he had to die come back rage out
for a second and then realize that he's
happy to be there and now we have a
Superman yeah II have a super we have a
Superman we want he's got brighter
costume and everything yeah an origin
story movies the big problem with the
with the Clark Kent scenes has nothing
to do with Henry cavils performance or
the writing of Superman it's the dam
behind the scenes reveal a little
freaking mustache because it's the mic
you can notice it way better than I
could but every time there was a close
up on his face I couldn't help but look
at his freaking lips yeah he like is it
there is the mustache thing there is
this post if I hadn't been told there
are definitely scenes where it is my
really notice of but there's so much bad
CGI nice movie that I might not notice
there is a lot of bad CGI and there are
times where I was sitting there going
okay they hit it pretty well there so if
you're not looking for it you might not
even see yeah but there are like they're
the the prologue of the movie and then
some of the later scenes I'm like oh he
has weird uncanny valley face you know
yeah there's so much other bad CG and
like bad greens green work and like
after a while nothing that feels real
and so it changes how you think about it
and certain things do sort of slide off
you like Atlantis the only thing that
got me
Woori first like future DC stuff like
hey I'm excited to flash I would love to
see cyborg my movie I'd love to see that
I'm excited for Wonder Woman to give me
whatever the next Batman adventure you
want but Aquaman when they go to
Atlantis so when they were in Atlantis
Oh most of Aquaman taking place because
this is not look very good the thing
their costumes under why not great I
really feel like with something like the
character is stepping off because he was
the most noticeably terrible see he
looked like a video game I think that
there's a big tricked into making CGI
work which is cinematography yeah
waiting if you watch The Hulk angley's
and then you watch The Incredible Hulk
the biggest dippers Battalion updated
special visual effects over the course
of like a couple years is the
cinematography they light them in
certain lighting were it's like same
thing with thor ragnarok that's
depending on certain lighting is when he
looks the most real and when he looks
baby and it's the same thing here but
Stefan Wolfe was always like some
brightly colored scene for some reason
you could always look fighting on Emma
Sakura which is an island with no trees
yeah and he was such an uninteresting
villain and they just gave him nothing
to work with
I feel bad again like for that actor you
know coming off Game of Thrones yeah
stuff it doesn't have anything that you
couldn't I don't think put a big bulky
dude into like is his armor and stuff
maybe his face sure but the rest of him
I have replaced him with a big bulky guy
and it would have remained the same cuz
his voice has changed he doesn't have
any interesting character moments or
dialogue and it is the same [ __ ] is that
sort of I need my special object so that
I can take my place as ruler of the
world and destroy everything the pair of
demons aren't cool I mean it does
nothing to make that any more
interesting than that the midpoint of
this movie is when they they have the
whole you guys ran away from flash yeah
they only see Gordon is when they go to
see Guana
main scene that's like the midpoint of
the movie that's more like okay there's
a team actually assembling here okay
right that most of the way cuz then
Aquaman still is like on his way so
that's like the midpoint of the movie
the thing though is is that the way I
could tell us where you
to feel is the first like ten 250
Michels to feel like a setup you're
supposed to get into Act two and I was
like okay I get it the recruiting game
that's the fun and games but that was
kind of ready in the setup the big issue
with structure is before they become a
team it feels like we've been watching a
45 minutes set up and the only reason I
know is 45 to 50 minutes is because some
[ __ ] turns on their [ __ ] phone
yeah I see 702 and the movie started at
6:20 like after the trailers were done
so I was like oh we're about 40 minutes
in it here's the scene yeah well yeah
and there's there also - at least from
my viewing experience of this in the
first half of the movie especially it
started to feel long because I had seen
so many of those moments in trailers and
clips and after a while I was like oh
there's not much scene around these
jokes it's like most the scenes are
pretty quick so yeah the stuff you've
seen before is mostly the way you see it
and after a while is like okay when's
the new stuff nice ones more I really
feel like with an extra 20 to 30 minutes
this movie could have been paced better
and we could have had more scenes that
feel like scenes they'll be constantly
amused yeah like yeah it's it's the
freaking Blake Snyder not Mike Snyder
who wrote save the cat cuz I know what
some legs gonna be like if you
complained that BBS was too long and
it's it's it's how you use your time
it's like this is a clippie two hours
everybody could have used a few moments
more to make us care it's intermittent
with like oh it's actually good and then
there's flaws I'm like I'm amused by how
it looks flawed the thing that really
bothered me if there's one like legit
strong thing that bothered me was why
was the CGI so bad in so many scenes
because there's some great CGI when
you're in Gotham that looks great often
looks real it looks great it looked like
Tim Burton's Batman and look like the
Frank Miller Batman so when they're
playing the Batman theme song you're
like that implies like hey you know it
looks fantastic even if that mascara
that's distracting Atlantis is
distracting Steppenwolf the big final
battle I really wish they handled like
the parademons and all that better
because they just opened up with Batman
fine you know they're they're not overly
menacing yeah they're pretty easy to
wipeout
yes they're mostly annoying because
there are so many of them one thing I
will give that I
didn't like about this movie
intrinsically and for the point of what
it is is how the team ultimately comes
together because in the Avengers if
we're you know you're gonna look and
compare a little bit and part of it is
they assemble the team get the team kind
of ready and then do the mega battle
yeah but in this one the team isn't
fully there until the very end when
Superman comes when a Superman comes in
oh yeah
Superman breath revealed that was yes
waiting for that of his damn new
Superman movie and it was nice and it
was perfect because it was more than
just oh he's using a couple parademons
he used it to help Wonder Woman we sure
helped with the t2 the villain fight and
it was it was a neat introduction with
Superman as you saw what Batman was so
hell-bent on getting Superman back
because the Superman shows up like the
team has nothing to worry about
Steppenwolf is like nothing yeah yeah
yeah it's like without him you're just
like oh you guys are all pretty strong
but you know how long can we keep on
like this and then Superman shows up
being like oh cool yeah great joke too
and flash saves the one family that we
keep randomly cutting back to you yeah
yeah the Superman was Superman this is
Superman this is real we won't want it
there's one thing you gotta give this
movie credit for all your complaints
you've had about man stealing BBS I'm
like they nailed Superman in this film
that earned them some serious points
with me yeah yeah I really am happy
about that because you know that was the
only still only the Superman stuff was
the stuff where I was surprised yeah
yeah yeah and I and I feel like that is
kind of telling too because we watched
so many trailers and clips and stuff
they made an effort to keep Superman
under wraps for this movie even in the
way they were introducing a Mekons and
stuff yeah and I feel like that paid off
for them they would joke around in
panels so not really hinted at what's
going on in to mislead oh this is the
one of the few cases where I'm happy to
have been misled by a trailer yeah
because he came in much earlier than I
was expecting in a way that I wasn't
expecting so they reinvented him for the
DC Universe in a great way I guess the
last thing to talk about is the
post-credits scene where we see Lex has
been broken out by the help of
Deathstroke and now it sounds like
they're setting up that
hi Justice League group yes we're lexer
it was like we need to have our own
league when I'm like are you going into
your own another week
are you are you already got Suicide
Squad and Justice League are you guys
already go on for the league thing you
said that I was like as I thought like
Oh deaths or zero that means we're gonna
get that Batman movie we've been talking
about yeah I'm glad Joe mangly on over
there the health element men I'm glad
he's still around because for a while
and like the press it's been like even
Sox like I don't know I'm glad they
didn't lose him I'm right he's still
Deathstroke and they look the costume
looks cool and everything this set up
didn't quite excitement well and now I'm
sitting here going so what is Lex gonna
be yeah because we've just reinvented a
few people have Lex P was a knee but he
was still you know he had that sort of
snappy verbose he still carried himself
a little different yes yeah there was
something when you're like they're doing
something different he's been through
prison yeah he's a man now he's not some
annoying any longer
alright guys but what were your favorite
scenes from the Justice League movie put
your spoiler comments down below spoiler
alert II idiot who comes to a spoiler
review and looks like comments put it
down below down serves them right for
for looking or accidentally clicking cuz
they thought it wasn't a spoiler review
or coming back to their computer after
somebody else has used it and scrolled
yeah element section or the autoplay of
the non-spoiler went on what a way to
ruin you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow us on social media especially at
the Stardust app download all the app at
the real rejects and become a patron
eject today do it man great communities
on both ends come give us a hug love you
guys